i've always been obsessed with how
things sound
it's the difference between a great song
and an iconic recording
[Music]
i am mark bronson and whenever someone
sits down to play me a song
i'm already thinking about the sound
be impressive sound
matters and when i first started out i
wondered how did they do that
when rat songs started having drum
machines that was like oh i got to get
your own machine
just like that you can turn any noise
into music
just like that we were constantly
searching for new sound
i made a whole album with one of these
where did you actually sample the
seagulls how how about
things i think it's just me pure genius
these machines are used to create the
sounds of the people that are not in the
mainstream
there's only so much that we can do with
language the whole world open up wait a
minute
you started to see bedroom producers let
me do a little editing
the next person that is going to change
music has no idea how to play the guitar
is this allowed to happen i've been
doing it wrong for 30 years
don't believe me just watch i didn't
need
words i just needed sounds
this is a pv decade i can't believe this
is really happening right now
you can do anything you want to do you
start obsessing over it
it doesn't have to follow any format
i believe in happy accidents only
criteria is what
it better be funky
we're just getting started
you